[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu Skyblock mit Luca
Folge 3 meine Damen und Herren und der
ein oder andere Witz jetzt vielleicht
gerade denken Mensch Luca der letzte
Folge Folge 2 am Ende hast du gesagt
die nächste Folge startet mit einer
timeless ich stehe hier und schaue mir
diesen Baum an und diese glüh
leuchtbären die sie wachsen und erst
dann geht's weiter weil ich keinen Bock
habe mehr zu warten die Sache ist
allerdings dass man dann das hier
geschrieben wurde und deswegen mache ich
jetzt doch keine timelapse weil Phantome
ihr kennt sie alle das sind diese
Viecher Mischung aus einem Insekten
Libelle und Dinosaurier die kommen alle
Minecraft wenn man nicht genügend
schläft und da wir kein Bett haben
können wir auch nicht schlafen
denn für Network logischerweise wolle
wir haben keine Wolle und wir können uns
zwei wolle craften dafür bräuchten wir
allerdings Fäden bekommen wir wiederum
nur von Spinnen die bekomme wiederum nur
wenn wir die Monster Farmen bauen das
könnte ich eigentlich in der nächsten
Folge machen also gebt mir gern mal
Tipps und in die Kommentare für eine
Monster Farben die kann ich ja dann
irgendwie hier so vorne hin bauen die
muss ein bisschen entfernt sind auf
jeden Fall vielleicht Spawner dann
irgendwie Spinnen und vielleicht spawnen
da auch Skelette denn dann bekommen wir
Knochen aus den Knochen können wiederum
Knochen Mehl machen und dann können wir
hier vorne deswegen kann ich auch mal
das Gras hier abbauen ach guck mal wir
direkt einen Samen rausbekommen perfekt
deswegen tatsächlich nur einsam sehr gut
dann können wir mit dem Knochenmehl
einerseits hier bei der Glühbirne mal
draufklicken das wird auch in die
Kommentare geschrieben dass ja man da
irgendwie mit Baum hier vorgehen muss
ich weiß es nicht so ganz ich glaube ich
werde bei der klassischen Weizen fahren
bleiben wird mit Brote machen classi und
wir können mit den Knochenmehl auf jeden
Fall auch hier direkt aufmachen dann
bekommen wir noch mehr krass deswegen
konnte ich das jetzt auch mal abbauen
genau die nächste Sache die ich euch
sagen wollte war dass ich doch nicht in
diese Richtung heute gehen ich werde da
vorne ich weiß ein Fichtenbaum ich liebe
Fichten ich liebe das Holz was man
daraus machen kann ich liebe die Bretter
ich liebe die Fichtenholz Falltüren ihr
wisst mein Fichtenholz Fetisch noch aus
Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1 ich weiß
nicht was das daneben ist ob das eine
Truhe ist
oder ein Kürbis oder eine Kiss ich habe
keine Ahnung jeden Fall werden wir nicht
dorthin gehen sondern wir werden uns
heute in diese Richtung da hinten
vorbauen denn ich habe ein bisschen
recherchiert und habe im Skyblock Forum
gelesen dass dort angeblich Wasser sein
soll und wenn wir denn wir haben ja
einmal hier vorne drin hier ne wenn wir
dann das Wasser von dort vorne mitnehmen
und hier vorne hinsetzen haben wir nun
endlich Wasserquelle das heißt wir
können das dann nutzen um beispielsweise
noch ein See zu bauen das ist auch ein
Teil der challenges der 60 challenges
die wir ja bis Silvester machen wollen
in diesem Projekt wir können das Wasser
dann nutzen um hier vorne eine
Weizenfarm hinzubauen generell das wird
sich alles hier noch voll verändern ne
ihr müsst im Projekt wirklich Zeit geben
und ich hoffe ihr macht das Ganze
deswegen habe ich auch gesagt es wird
ein ruhiges Projekt nehmt euch eine
Tasse Tee ich weiß ich bin gerade ein
bisschen üblich aber ich bin aufgeregt
ich habe Bock ich habe mich so doll
vorbereitet auf diese Folge nehmt euch
eine Tasse Tee oder manuellen Kaffee
oder ein Kakao oder keine Ahnung was
legt euch ins Bett oder auf Sofa schaut
euch die Folge an es wird auf jeden Fall
sehr sehr entspannt was ich auf jeden
Fall machen möchte ist dass ich hier so
einen kleinen Marktplatz bauen werde der
Cobblestone Generator der wird noch ein
bisschen umfällig der wird woanders hin
gemacht denke ich mal allerdings wird
hier vorne auf jeden Fall meine Hütte
stehen hier im Haus stehen hier vorne
werde ich ein Weizenfarm hin bauen
vielleicht noch eine melonenfamilie hin
hierhin dann Sie vielleicht eine
kürbisfarben denn hier vorne ein paar
Bäume also so ein Wald generell in die
wächst das nicht ne
ich könnte mal die Fackel daneben
platzieren
wenn ich dann ein bisschen mehr Licht
hat
wir wissen ja alle Pflanzen brauchen
Licht ne vielleicht aber auch noch ein
bisschen Wasser brauchen Pflanzen glaube
ich nicht in Minecraft naja auf jeden
Fall werden wir uns heute nicht da vorne
hin bauen sondern da vorne und da ja ich
kann eben auch schon mal ein bisschen
bustern aber nutzen wir die Zeit dann
quatsche
bei 3 Minuten wenn man nichts geschafft
wirklich gar nichts äh jetzt habe ich
den Block da aus Versehen abgebaut
dahinter das wird mir auch unten in die
Kommentare geschrieben Luca setz hinter
den Block den du hier abbaust bei einem
Cobblestone Generator eine anderen
Cobblestone so dass du gedrückt halten
kannst ich halte jetzt gedrückt und das
klappt auch damit vorhin habe ich so
abgebaut weil immer der erste Block das
seht ihr jetzt guck mal ich brauche
jetzt die ganze Nacht
gleicher Rhythmus wenn ich einmal kurz
aufhöre wenn ich jetzt wieder abbaue
ist es nicht mehr der gleiche Rhythmus
jetzt ist es allerdings wieder die Sache
ist deswegen werde ich dort auch keinen
Bruchstein hinter setzen sondern
normalen Erdblock beibehalten wir müssen
das Gras behalten wir müssen das Gras
hier lassen und deswegen will ich hier
zu wenig grad wie möglich irgendwie
Abbauen von daher erst Block abbauen
kurz warten zweiten abbauen und jetzt
kann ich die ganze Zeit abbauen ohne
dass sie irgendwie was passiert ähm ich
werde und da komme ich jetzt auch gleich
oder jetzt direkt schon zum zum Problem
der heutigen Folge denn sorry dass ich
hier wirklich so viel Quatsch ist wird
eine absolute Lava Folge aber ich habe
so viele eure Kommentare gelesen und ich
möchte auch dankbar für so schreibt mir
gerne weiteren Tipps und in die
Kommentare ich habe ein kleines Problem
was wir hier zu Gesicht bekommen haben
in der in dem Projekt Skyblock mit Luca
denn ich habe ja eigentlich überlegt
dass ich zu jeder Insel und es gibt ja
nicht nur unsere standardinsel sondern
es gibt ja noch 9 weitere Inseln ne hier
außenrum die neuen und da vorne diesen
komischen Tennisball wo sieht man ihn da
sieht man ihn gerade eingeblendet die
gibt's ja auch noch mit diesem komischen
zafiren da drin ist und was ist ja auch
noch gibt ist wenn man beispielsweise
ich weiß keine Ahnung aber wenn man auf
die Insel geht kann sein dass man von
dort noch andere Inseln am Ende des
Horizont sieht wie beispielsweise sind
ozeanmonument oder was gibt es da noch
da gab es noch einen
räuberturm oder Pyramiden also es gibt
noch andere Orte die es hier zu
entdecken gibt außer diese neuen Inseln
die wir eh schon haben deswegen haben
wir ein kleines buchsteinproblem klar
wir können unendlich viel Bruchstein
hier vorne abbauen das ist allerdings
sehr langweilig sehr träge und sehr
zeitaufwendig für mich und wenn ich
jeden Weg so machen würde bis da vorne
ich habe das mal ausgerechnet dann wären
das insgesamt mehr als 6000
Bruchstein Stufen allein wir nehmen
müssen weil das sind irgendwie ein knapp
200 Blöcke bis zu jeder Insel hier hin
und hier bis da vorne das mal drei weil
wir ein dreierweg machen sind schon mal
600 Blöcke nur von hier bis dahin
theoretisch dass da noch mal zwei weil
wir zu der Insel da hinten auch noch hin
müssen sondern bei 1200 nur damit wir
diese beiden Inseln über unsere
Hauptinsel verbinden dann müssen wir
allerdings noch diese Inseln verbinden
wir müssen noch diese Inseln verbinden
und dann das noch mal horizontal ihr
könnt euch das gerne mal selber
ausrechnen und da kommen dann nämlich
auch noch die diese ganz normalen
Bruchstein am Rand zu und auch die
Mauern das heißt das werden wir lassen
ich habe allerdings eine Kompromiss
überlegt der glaube ich auch in eurem
Interesse ist weil das Projekt
eigentlich auch ein bisschen schneller
ein bisschen an Fahrt aufnimmt denn ich
werde mir diese bruchsteinstufen craften
werde mich auch rüber bauen zu den
Inseln logischerweise ich muss da hin
allerdings werde ich dann diese Inseln
einfach unter Mauern nennt man das so
unter keine Ahnung was ich werde die
bruchsteinstufen auf jeden Fall unter
die Insel packen so dass ich die
komplette Insel abbauen werde
und die ganzen Sachen die sich auf der
Insel befinden mit auf meine Insel
nehmen werde also dass wir nachher keine
Inseln mehr außenrum haben sondern nur
unsere standardinsel mit all den Sachen
von den Inseln außenrum das heißt wir
haben dann auf unserer Insel so einen
Bereich wo wir beispielsweise so ein
bisschen dass er so wüstenmäßig haben
mit Kakteen mit sowas in die Richtung
wir werden allerdings auch im Bereich
haben wo wir eher so Pilze haben werden
auch ein Bereich haben wo wir alles mit
Fichtenholz machen werden wir werden den
kleinen See haben wir werden einen
Farbbereich haben alles natürlich mit
sehr wenig Ressourcen das heißt wir
können jetzt nicht so eine riesen
inselprojekt Stadt bauen so wie wir es
in Minecraft Lukas Staffel 1 gemacht
dann das Projekt ging ja auch fast über
ein Jahr oder ein halbes 3/4 Jahr ging
ja auch Minecraft mit Lukas Staffel 1
das ist hier natürlich nicht so ganz der
Fall die Sache ist allerdings das jetzt
erstmal meine Spitzhacke jeden Moment
kaputt sein wird und zwar genau
jetzt allerdings der auch gerade schon
oben eingeblendet haben wir jetzt auch
die erste Challenge für heute geschafft
wir haben 64 Cobblestone am Stück
abgebaut das war eine Challenge die ich
auf jeden Fall auch meine Liste hatte
jetzt ein sehr unnötige Challenge weil
sie uns absol nicht weiterbringt aber
wir brauchen die Cobblestone tatsächlich
um uns die Stufen zu machen und bevor
ich es vergesse werde ich mir auch ganz
kurz bevor ich jetzt alles hier
verbrannte auch noch mal eben eine neue
Spitzhacke hier vorne machen zack da
haben wir die auf jeden Fall auch am
Start alles wieder hier rein was wir am
besten nicht verlieren sollten die
Mauern bei euch nicht das brauche ich
nicht und hieraus kann ich auch noch mal
eben Hochstein Stufen machen ich hoffe
dass das reichen sollte das sind jetzt
insgesamt knapp 160 bruchsteinstufen von
daher euch die erste timelapse des
heutigen Videos ey wir sind hier schon
wieder bei 8 Minuten und ich habe noch
keine einzige timelapse gemacht ich habe
noch einmal wirklich Luft geholt ganz
kurze timelapse
[Musik]
was ist das
ich hoffe mal das ist nur ein
Grafikfehler
ich hoffe mal dass das jetzt nicht noch
mal auftritt
ich habe extra nur Sachen mitgenommen
wo es nicht schlimm ist wenn ich sie
verliere weil ich habe nur steinsachen
in der Hand klar ist es blöd bei der
steinspitzhacke wenn ich die verliere
okay es ist ein Grafikfehler
ist gewachsen wow aber sind keine Beeren
dran oder
müssen wir mal schauen wenn wir noch
egal euch eine kurze timeless bis wir
dann drüben auf der anderen Insel sind
[Musik]
hey
ich habe keine bruchsteinstufen mehr
[Musik]
es sind vielleicht noch so 20 30 Blöcke
bis wir da vorne sind allerdings bringt
es mir jetzt eh nichts anzukommen weil
ich muss ja die Insel unterhöhlen das
heißt muss auch noch ein Eimer mitnehmen
mit Wasser weil ich dann ja die Insel
runter muss über einem Wasserfall um von
unten auf Steine zu setzen das wird
ziemlich risky weil wenn ich das
verlieren sollte dann sind wir auf jeden
Fall am Arsch aber ich hoffe dass man
einfach dass ich das hinkriege auf jeden
Fall euch noch mal eine ganz kurze
timelapse wie ich noch ein bisschen
Bruchsteine abbaue und die ganzen Sachen
abhole
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
ich habe mich gerade voll erschrocken
dass meine Spitzhacke kaputt gegangen
ist
ich bin gerade nebenbei am gucken wie
man es irgendwie hinkriegen kann dass
ein Baum schneller wächst aber das Video
ist auch von vor elf Jahren Minecraft
Tutorials German schnell baumwachsen
lassen naja weil der Baum ist doch immer
nicht gewachsen ich bin in der rudertei
bei 20 Minuten ich weiß nicht woran das
liegt klar wir können mit baumail
draufgehen aber wir haben keinen Baum
mehr das ist halt das Problem
was ich allerdings schon mal eben
nebenbei machen könnte wäre fällt mir
gerade auf ich könnte schon mal das hier
nutzen um das Weizen schon mal an zu
pflanzen dann mache ich das einfach hier
vorne und müssen jetzt aufpassen dass er
nicht drauf treten aber da können wir
ein bisschen
oh warte mal wir haben nicht nur ist sie
die Place gerade erzählt also das
Minecraft ich schief mit sondern auch
das hier
es ist ja genau genommen eine Weizenfarm
ist zwar nur ein Block aber naja
ich stelle mir das eh nachher ein
bisschen anders ne hier Weizenfarm ist
noch weiter gewachsen hier weizenfarben
ne corpion Generator ein bisschen rüber
ja vorhin schon gesagt das soll hier so
ein riesiger geiler Marktplatz werden
dann nehmen wir alle Materialien rüber
damit so eine kleine sandäcker mit
dieser wieder gut ich sollte auf jeden
Fall genug Sachen haben werde
dementsprechend das jetzt hier umwandeln
zu bruchsteinstufen und werde jetzt auch
mein Eimer mitnehmen und
mir vielleicht auch noch eine Axt machen
fällt mir gerade auf also wäre
vielleicht auch noch sinnvoll damit wir
den Baum da hinten halt einfach gut
abbauen können zack eine Axt so und eine
Schaufel wäre vielleicht auch sinnvoll
weil wir auch eine Menge Erde da hinten
haben das ist nämlich auch das Ding ähm
heute dass ich trotzdem mal hier die
Bruchsteinmauer die kann ich hier vorne
auch erstmal noch hinsetzen ja ist halt
das Ding ich würde gerne zu jeder Insel
Sonnenweg bauen aber ich glaube wir sind
uns alle einig das ist ein bisschen
Touch und dann haben wir alles voll mit
riesigen Brücken dann mache ich lieber
so kleine die man vielleicht irgendwann
mal wieder abbauen kann aber gut haben
wir alles ich nehme das Wasser mal mit
erstmal
wenn ich jetzt drauf gekriegt man den oh
mein Gott okay weil ich dachte schon
nicht dass er dann zu trocken wird und
dann droppt dann merke ich das nicht
okay nehmen wir das hier mit hier sollte
nichts passieren dass der Körper kaputt
machen genau dann wird das auch wieder
zu Gras erstmal ey der Baum ne das
wirklich einfach nur noch frech guck mal
hier die glühbären die kann weiter
können die nicht wachsen diese Glühwein
Pflanze ah das passt wirklich quatscher
der das nicht hinkriegt naja gut also
wir laufen auf jeden Fall nach der
hinten ich trau mich auch immer nicht zu
sprinten weil ich habe noch alle Hunger
kommen wir springen jetzt einmal können
wir machen wie ich glaube das sollte
jetzt nicht direkt irgendwie auf unsere
hungerbalken gehen dass wir direkt was
verlieren das dauert ja eigentlich ein
bisschen
geht sie müssen schneller so was wir auf
jeden Fall machen werden ist die
komplette Insel jetzt abbauen ich werde
mein Wasser einmal nehmen ich werde ihn
an der Seite der Insel runter fließen
lassen so dass ich von unten Bruchsteine
platzieren kann ich darf währenddessen
nicht sterben ich darf nicht
runterfallen sonst ist mein Wasser
einmal weg mit und wir können uns ja
kein neu machen ne ist ja Eisen ne haben
wir natürlich nicht wärmer keine Höhlen
ist immer noch nicht gewachsen das ist
so ein Quatsch ne was mir übrigens auch
in die Kommentare geschrieben wurde wenn
ich hier gerade schon hier komplett am
labern bin war das hier das Projekt ist
nicht vorbei wenn ich keine Sätze raus
kriege erinnert mich wahrscheinlich an
Skype mit Luca Folge 1 da habe ich
gesagt scheiße wenn wir hier keinen
Setzling rauskriegen dann ist das
Projekt vorbei weil wir dann kein Holz
kriegen na ja das ist ja auch Holz oder
ist das Holz
das sieht so komisch aus
warte mal
was ist denn das
Mangroven Wurzeln
ich dachte das wäre ein Baum
naja egal wir haben auf jeden Fall da
hinten bauen dass ich von hier und wir
haben da auf jeden Fall auch ein Baum
also Holz haben wir auf jeden Fall genug
das heißt wir müssen uns jetzt nicht um
jeden Setzling irgendwie streiten aber
es wir haben halt nur eine Eiche und wir
haben nur diesen einen Eichen das heißt
wir müssen schon hoffen dass er noch ein
bisschen was rauskommt aber gut wir
bauen mal die Mango Wurzeln ja oder was
auch immer das ist ich habe zwar keine
Ahnung wofür das brauchen und wir haben
hier auf jeden Fall unendliche
Wasserquelle habe ich die Spitzhacke mit
perfekt ich habe nicht mehr
ich habe mir keine Spitzhacke gemacht
welche Idiot
ist aber nicht schlimm wir sollten
vielleicht auch ohne Spitzhacke
hinkriegen deswegen
die Mission beginnt meine Damen und
Herren
wir setzen das Wasser hin und müssen
jetzt hier runter
wir müssen die komplette Insel
[Musik]
unterhöhlen
wir müssen komplett
Bruchstein hier drunter setzen
sollten es aber gepackt haben glaube ich
also schwierig war das jetzt nicht
ehrlich gesagt
ich bräuchte jetzt halt nur eine
spitzhack um das abzubauen obwohl
bräuchten wir vielleicht auch nicht mehr
wir können auch hier die Erde mitnehmen
was ist denn das hier überhaupt
das ist schlammige mangrovenwurz was ist
das für ein Quatsch hier
das klingt können wir auch nicht abbauen
weil das ist ja
ich habe auch den Wassereimer gar nicht
also jetzt Wasser da lassen können ich
kann hier das Wasser hätte ich auch
nehmen was Quatsch
ich bin verpeilt bisschen ich habe auch
ein bisschen Respekt vor diesem ganzen
Projekt weil ich könnte jederzeit runter
fliegen ich kenne meine Tastatur die
Macht offen bisschen später ne ich
könnte jeden Moment runter fliegen ich
könnte jeden Moment irgendwie könnten
diese Phantome auftreten weil ich schon
so lange nicht geschlafen habe überlegt
weil sinnfolge drei das ist locker als
mittlerweile schon so anderthalb Stunden
Spielzeit oder so die ich hier in diesem
Projekt habe die könnten langsam kommen
die könnt mich jeden Moment töten wenn
jetzt sie von der Seite kommen ich fall
runter ist der Wassereimer weg also wir
sind die den ganzen Tag wir sind zu
jeder Zeit 24/7 absoluten Gefahren
ausgesetzt und haben auch ganz ganz
wenig Items das heißt wenn ich einfach
mal sterbe ist das Projekt fast schon
vorbei weil ich halt nicht noch mehr was
daran komme also setzen wir mal das
Wasser hier hin ich mache mir mal eben
kurz eine neue Spitzhacke noch mal eben
damit wir auch das entspannt mitnehmen
können und da vorne alles abbauen können
und jetzt aber eben kurz nachdenken muss
ich noch irgendwas mitnehmen ich glaube
nicht die Hacke kann ich auch hier
lassen die brauche ich auf jeden Fall
sollte passen denke ich hier ist noch
immer nichts gewachsen und ich habe auch
schon zweieinhalb hungerbalken verloren
ich blende euch den ganz kurze timeless
ein
timelaps wie ich da hinten hin laufe und
die komplette Insel abbaue
was ist das
ich habe keine Art ich habe das noch nie
gesehen in Minecraft ne ich weiß nicht
ob das irgendein Monsters oder ob das
irgendwas ist was gerade ist aber
ich würde das jetzt so erstmal stehen
lassen das wichtigste habe ich
mitgenommen und zwar 8 Erde das
Seerosenblatt Mangrovenwurzeln keine
Ahnung was das ist und halt stammige
Mangroven Wurzeln auch noch hier oben
kriegen wir bestimmt noch den anderen
Setzling raus die Sache ist allerdings
dass ich mich jetzt gerade nicht traue
das weiter abzubauen weil ich nicht weiß
ob das so eine Art Bienennest ist
blöde Erfahrungen in Minecraft mit Luger
Staffel 1 wo mich Bienen tatsächlich
verfolgt haben und fast getötet haben
allerdings bin ich da mal wieder auf
eure Hilfe angewiesen
ich würde das jetzt einfach mal so
lassen
das können wir uns vielleicht am
nächsten Folge angucken also schreibt
mir gerne ein paar Kommentare hier
drunter generell Tipps etc sehr sehr
gern gesehen ich liebe das anzugucken
abends immer
dann könnt ihr mir sagen ob das
gefährlich ist oder nicht es hat auf
jeden Fall alles geklappt mehr oder
weniger ich habe jetzt dahin noch nicht
alles abgebaut weil ich halt nicht weil
ich will nicht weiter abbauen ich kenne
das nicht was das ist ich habe ein
Wassereimer den werde ich jetzt gleich
da hinten platzieren dann haben wir auf
jeden Fall auch noch die unendliche
Wasserquelle dementsprechend heute drei
Achievements geschafft drei challenges
einmal die weizenfarben einmal 64
Cobblestone am Stück abbauen und dann
die unendliche Wasserquelle und ich sehe
schon wieder da rechts der Baum ist noch
immer nicht gewachsen sorry aber woran
liegt denn das wieso braucht dieser
verdammte eichensetzling so lange zum
wachsen weil wir haben jetzt auch da
hinten kein Holz bekommen klar wir
können mal gucken ob man da hinten
irgendwie noch einen Setzling
rausbekommt aber wir sind hier langsam
echt am Ende ne wir haben nur noch vier
eichenholzbretter und zwei Stecker also
so langsam müsste das hier wirklich mal
wachsen und die Phantome die kommen uns
auch immer näher aber gut wir machen auf
jeden Fall jetzt in dieser auch noch mal
eben kurz die unendliche Wasserquelle
dafür werde ich das mal eben hier kurz
ein bisschen erweitern unsere flächig
ich werde die auch grün machen so dass
wir hier alles so ein bisschen schön und
passend haben wird aber natürlich
untermauern mit Bruchsteinen so dass
auch uns nichts hier irgendwie verloren
geht also zack zack zack so hier runter
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack und
dann hier vorne zack zack zack und auch
hier vorne zack zack zack zack zack so
dass wir hier die Mauer dann setzen
können dementsprechend die Steinmauern
hier vorne drauf BAM und dann können wir
hier das ganze mit der Erde die wir neu
bekommen haben so ein bisschen erweitern
das wird jetzt nicht ganz ausreichen
diesen Block hier nehme ich mal weg und
wir können ja auch so ein bisschen
schummeln wir können ja
den Block hier drunter den sieht man ja
eh nicht den können wir ja oh mein Gott
boah oh mein Gott gerade noch so
gerettet ah okay ich wäre eh nicht
runtergefallen aber gut den sieht man ja
eh nicht dann können wir das mal eben
kurz so machen da fehlt uns immer noch
eine Block verdammt
bei den lassen wir offen wenn wir Blöcke
abbauen dass die dann vielleicht auch
dahin gehen keine Ahnung irgendwas
total blöd wieder von mir gedacht ne für
unendliche Wasserquelle müssen wir das
ja eh frei lassen dann hätten wir die
Erde auch da lassen können komm einfach
nur für mein Gewissen machen wir das
jetzt trotzdem hier setzen wir hier
einfach mal wieder
Idiot das gleiche Situation gerade oh
mein Gott Alter na egal okay machen wir
hier vorne auf jeden Fall ein Wasser hin
zack zack und wir haben nun endlich
Wasserquelle ihr seht schon ich kann
jeden einmal rausnehmen zack egal was
hier ist geht immer wieder rein also wir
haben genügend Wasser meine Damen und
Herren wir haben mit den Generator es
war eine sehr sehr produktive Folge es
hat mich sehr sehr doll gefreut ich
werde mal wieder alles hier reinpacken
was ich gerade aktuell nicht benötige
Schaufel Alter ein bisschen mitnehmen
ich werde jetzt auch mal hier vorne
ich habe ein bisschen Angst dass sie an
zu pflanzen wegen der Lava weil wir wenn
das hier überschwappt dann wenn was
anfängt zu brennen das ist immer nicht
so geil aber ich werde das jetzt einfach
mal so lassen
so dass wir ich mach mal wieder meine
Standard Anordnung hier einen Schwert
brauche ich denke ich jetzt erstmal
nicht das brauche ich jetzt auch erstmal
nicht so würde ich das jetzt erstmal
lassen dann haben wir hier vorne schon
mal leicht was angepflanzt wir haben die
Weizen fahren wir haben die unendlich
Wasserquelle wir haben 64 haben wir
haben drei geile challenges geschafft
heute was wir nicht geschafft haben ist
dass der Baum wächst
kommt hoffentlich in der nächste Folge
wenn ihr Tipps habt schreibt unten rein
lassen Daumen hoch und dann wieder da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke wenn ihr weiter Videos
verpassen wollt es geht tatsächlich erst
in drei Tagen weiter
übermorgen noch nicht morgen kommt
erstmal goat Simulator dann brauche ich
übermorgen mal einen Tag Pause ich bin
da auch in Frankfurt unterwegs also ich
habe da ein bisschen was zu tun und dann
geht's Freitag weiter mit Skyblock
drückt die Daumen dass der Baum wächst
haut rein ciao
[Musik]